there's some sort of veil being lifted
on our monetary system
where compared to right now our monetary
system is
managed by the either the federal
reserve or the central bank the united
states government
they're trying their best i'm sure right
but do they always get it right no they
don't always get it right and do they
have undue control
and have they over the past you know 10
to 20 years
um printed money more in favor of
like the establishment and the banking
system this is back to the cantillon
cantilion effect that we were talking
about earlier where where this money
printing
is not going to average citizens in the
u.s
it's going to bankers and people who
hold assets that's why if you want to
play the
monetary game in the united states you
can't just hold dollars
in a savings account anymore right like
you're not making any money that way you
have to play the game you have to buy
assets you have to invest
and so people are saying well should a
small group of
individuals in washington be able to
uh to to turn the dials on the money
system what happens if
they become corrupt and so this is a
ground-up movement
to say no we want to build our money
system and by the way
not just central banking but also
commercial banking on credibly
neutral protocols where um you know the
the
that can't be biased that can't be
corrupted
[Music]
[Music]
okay welcome back to the next episode of
yang
speaks in the next episode of our
limited series
the future of folks today we are talking
about something that touches everybody
we are talking about the future of money
yes the future of money and frankly is
the future of cryptocurrency
which is probably our future we brought
on i've got two people on this podcast
one you all know and love carly riley
was our finance director on the
presidential but
if you listen to this podcast you know
she called
robin hood blowing up the stock market
in our bold predictions for 2021 so she
is essentially a guru in this and really
sees
the markets very very interestingly in
my opinion um so i wanted her
perspective but the
the crypto expert we brought on as a guy
i've really got to know and
and and like a lot his name is ryan sean
adams so he's a crypto investor but he's
the creator of
the bankless newsletter and podcast and
what bankless does
it was perfect for me frankly in this
but it helps you
understand what crypto is and how this
whole
ecosystem works but also starts getting
you on the path
of getting away from your bank and
getting into
the cryptocurrency world so if you're
like
i think a lot of the yang gang which is
crypto curious or crypto fans but don't
really understand it this is the perfect
101 episode to start and then it gets
into more complicated stuff so we're
talking about what cryptocurrency is
we're talking about how why it's taking
off why people are passionate about it
how people are using it but then
i want to talk about the future of it
how it's working how it's going to
impact our lives what this
means and frankly how important is for
not just
white dudes like me to get involved now
how we need to get
the people it's meant to help if this is
going to democratize our economy and our
financial system
we need people of all frankly all sorts
of backgrounds and makes
make a very conscious effort towards um
inclusion in terms of this building
process because if we don't like our
current system
when we rebuild the next one we have to
do it better than the last time or we
end up with the same situation so
we talk about that a lot it's a
fascinating episode
i'm pretty confident you guys are gonna
like this so join me join ryan join
carly
talking about the future of money on
yank speaks
[Music]
all right welcome to the next episode
our limited series the future of and
today we are talking about
something that touches all of us the
future of money
the future of that cash money or let's
say lack of
cash money um depending on what we end
up where we end up as a society
and i'm excited today um so i'm joined
today by
i'm gonna call her our recurring co-host
carly riley many of you who are
in the yang universe and in the yang
gang are familiar with carly she was our
finance director on the presidential is
now working
um at a venture fund called kairos
is we're not gonna call i'm not gonna
call you a crypto expert
carly by any means but you do know
uh how to raise money and you do
understand the financing you worked at a
hedge fund before so
i'm happy to have your perspective
thanks for joining and i once made three
thousand dollars on monero
wow not because i'm narrating about it
yeah that's obscure well done
there it is and that love that smooth
silky voice you hear
next to carly's is ryan sean adams um
we're glad you're here ryan ryan is a
crypto investor
and the creator of something i found
fascinating um it's called bankless in
the bankless newsletter
and podcast and ryan will tell you a lot
more about this as we go but what they
are really great at is
frankly lowering the barrier to get
people in the crypto game now that's
probably not even how he would want to
describe it but that's how the
idiot um zach described it as he as he
took the bankless uh
like crash course before so ryan thanks
for joining welcome to the future of
money on yank speaks
oh my god i'm so excited to be here i
think it is about time for
yang gang and the crypto community to to
unite to meet
this is a great uh cross section it's
kind of like a marvel team up
so i am pumped for this episode guys
it's fun because
um this is my general sense of the yang
gang right now and i don't know
hopefully you guys listening to this
where it's like
we're all crypto friendly i think where
it's where people see cryptocurrency
moving like yeah
money new you know like
anti-establishment like screw the banks
through wall street this is new it's
interesting power the people
but then the reality is most of us
probably don't really know how it
works um or the the in the nitty
gritties of it maybe write an article or
two maybe even bought some bitcoin or
bought some ethereum bought something
but you're maybe kind of a novice in
this and i know certainly i
am that's how i've fit in here um so
what i wanted to do i wanted to take
this i kind of wanted to cover
um three things one i wanted to do a
kind of a basic one-on-one on
cryptocurrency what it is how it works
um so for those of you who've like been
talking a big game maybe don't actually
know the ins and outs like we can dive
in
then i wanted to level set where we are
today and lastly
i want to talk about what this means as
a society like where this looks like in
10
20 years because i think it's been 12
years or so since crypto really kind of
started
it's come a long way and it's got a long
way to go so ryan why don't we start
with that as carly and i kind of just
pick your brain here like
give us a little bit about yourself
where you started but then start to give
us this
like the basic answer to what the heck
is cryptocurrency how does it work
yeah so like i guess a little bit about
me what i love about crypto
is that uh i'm just a regular guy so
just a regular guy
on the crypto journey um you know i i
started
in healthcare tech somewhat like uh
andrew yang uh
2014 i discovered bitcoin got into
crypto
that way and then i just fell down the
rabbit hole and that's how many people
in crypto will describe the feeling of
learning about this new money system
it's just falling down the rabbit hole
and i like to say like many millennials
i was born too early for the internet
but i was born just in time for crypto
and this feels just as big and as
impactful as the early internet so
i uh i found myself sucked into crypto i
quit my corporate job in 2017.
i was in healthcare tech so i was at a
company called premier is a large
uh hospital group purchasing
organization that had some healthcare
informatics stuff anyway
so i jumped out and um like i like to
i like to say now uh i don't work for a
company any longer i work for
algorithms i work for protocols as weird
as that is but i think more and more of
us
will find that we work for these crypto
money things these crypto protocols in
the future
and we can get into that so i started
bank list it's a
newsletter podcast program in 2019 with
my co-host and we just help people
go on what we call zack the the bankless
journey
which is basically i'm sure we'll get
into this but it's basically
uh using these crypto systems as your
banking system
rather than traditional banks rather
than jp morgan or
a wells fargo using it in your everyday
life so it's more than just
buying crypto and holding it for the
long term it's actually using
crypto to go bankless you talk about
like going down this rabbit hole
and that being a common journey for
folks like what does that look like
where did that start sort of you're
starting to discover cryptocurrency
or bitcoin i imagine specifically like
what is bitcoin how do people get sucked
in this rabbit hole and like what were
you learning in that process
well so i think it's important to
understand like what
crypto really is because there's tons of
buds buzzwords you know
you know blockchains like what is that
there's there's bitcoin there's ethereum
there's this thing that you may have
heard of called decentralized finance
now that's cropping up more and more so
like what are all these buzzwords
really really to me what crypto is is
it's a
it's a social movement this is about
money by the people
for the people because the key thing
that it does the benefit that it
provides people and that it provides
society is that it allows anyone in the
world
access to a banking system anyone in the
world
so uh your geography shouldn't dictate
the banking system quality that you have
and crypto eliminates geography all you
need is an internet connection
and a keyboard and you can tap into the
best
banking system uh in the world it's also
a system of freedom so we could get into
this but
there are a lot of problems with the
central banking
and and uh how money is printed today
we've we've seen over the past you know
10 to 20 years this this what we call
the cantillian effect which is
whenever the money printer starts going
it tends to go to the people closest to
the money spigot
so it tends to go to the bankers and the
wealthy and we see that
in the form of asset inflation so the
last 10 years
right stocks have been on a tear real
estate's been on a tear
but wages they've been stagnate this is
because of the cantillian effect so
this essentially the movement is a money
system
by the people for for the people from
the ground up where everyone has access
to a credibly neutral
money system and that term super
important credibly neutral
money system how does it work let's
start with that's very simple
question i think there's lots of ways to
kind of explain
how it works right but but my favorite
way is
think about the early internet right and
so this is a this is a next evolution of
the internet so if you think of the
early internet as kind of like
the first internet it's it's really a
communication protocol right we can
create media on it
um but it lacked one thing it lacked the
ability to create
digital scarcity so everything on the
internet you can copy and paste right
so if um if there's a an image or if
there's some text or some content
i can copy paste i can replicate that
what cryptocurrency does
is it is it creates this like unlock for
civilization this unlock for humanity
and that unlock is digital scarcity so
cryptocurrency
unlike the rest of everything else on
the internet cannot be copied and pasted
if i own a bitcoin
it's mine you can't zack or carly you
can't just like
copy and paste that on a website and
make it yours so
in crypto they call this uh preventing
the the double spend problem
and that's really the societal
achievement the unlock
in in 2009 with the bitcoin white paper
and the bitcoin network
we created this next layer of the
internet next chapter of the internet
called digital scarcity and it turns out
that allows us to create really cool
things like
digital assets and the first thing we
decided to create with bitcoin
was a digital money or a digital store
of value so how crypto achieves this
is with cryptography right so we can
talk about that a little bit
plus economics right so it makes it very
costly to attack the network
and through those two mechanisms we've
created
digital scarcity i have a bitcoin
it's zach's got my own cryptography
let's call it fingerprint on it um and
then i
give it to carly in exchange for
something
is it still the exact same thing or is
it now carly's with her fingerprint on
it and something completely different
and my old bitcoin is disappeared
help me because i like dollars have
their own serial numbers on them so
technically you can't copy pay like how
did what
how is that different it's it's very
similar actually to dollars
right so the way to think about um
cryptocurrency is that it is a bearer
asset right and so what is a bearer
asset well in the physical world a bare
asset would be
um something that you hold and possess
and when you hand it to someone else or
give it to someone else
then they hold it and possess it they're
now in possession of it so
the most like famous bear asset that we
use in the real world is cash money
cash money when i give you cash money
zach or carly then i no longer hold that
20
dollar bill that i just gave you uh it's
gone from my possession
and then you then hold it right or gold
is similar in this way if i have a
nugget of gold or a gold bar and i give
it to you then i no longer own it and
you own it transaction complete and no
one can take it away from us
right that's the thing so other forms of
digital money if it's uh
numbers in your wells fargo account
right wells fargo you don't actually own
that
these are just uh representations of
money on the wells fargo like
ledger system you don't actually it's
not a bear asset if i buy a cup of
coffee at starbucks
i i've technically given them money but
realistically that actual cash money is
not
given to starbucks by the credit card
company for two three days is that like
am i picking up me putting down
exactly you're picking it up yeah so the
the key thing is there there's no
there's no middleman there's no visa in
the middle of this transaction there's
no wells fargo bank
zipper handing something to each other
it's just the same it's like
actual physical possession has just been
uh transmitted from me to you only it's
happened digitally that's what digital
scarcity gives us right
[Music]
new sponsor alert this episode of yank
speaks is brought to you by
calm so if you're quarantining in cobid
right now your routine has been
completely
disrupted and for me when i'm off my
routine i don't wind down the right way
and so when i'm on my phone i'm
scrolling that stuff like gives you
endorphins and it's tougher to fall
asleep
what i love about calm is that it helps
you
calm down and relax so we're excited to
partner with calm which is an app
designed to help you ease stress
and get the best sleep of your life and
when you relieve anxiety and improve
your sleep you feel better in every part
of your life what's great about it you
can be scrolling through your phone
you're like oh wait i need to go sleep i
need to calm down and pop open
the calm app it's got a whole library of
programs designed for healthy sleep like
soundscapes and meditations and 100
sleep stories narrated by beautiful
soothing voices like kelly rolling just
whispering sweet nothings in your ear as
you fall asleep so
listen to the show we're offering a
special limited time promotion of 40
off a calm premium subscription at
calm.com 40
off unlimited access to calm's entire
library with new content added every
week so get started today calm.com
yang that's calm.com
i think a lot of people know that
blockchain is somehow connected to
cryptocurrency
and to bitcoin can you explain
that role in this and and how that
impacts these transaction transactions
bitcoin is
is essentially a blockchain that's kind
of the technology that's the database
technology
um a number of years ago especially like
2015
it was sort of uh all the trend to talk
about well
blockchains are going to be important
but not bitcoin right so blockchain not
bitcoin
to me this kind of reminds me of sort of
the the early internet because
um like the idea in the early internet
was all of these companies would have
their own private intranets
right just a corporate wide internet
like a sharepoint or something
like that um but but what really ended
up happening is
is some of that happened and those are
like private blockchains
but the true value for society the big
unlock
happened on the public internet right
when we could combine
all of these other intranets that
various companies had and pull them in
into one communication protocol so we
could all transmit that so
um the the blockchain not bitcoin
movement
kind of faded away a little bit because
what turned out to be
the most important was the the public
blockchains themselves the bitcoins the
ethereum these are the things that are
open and permissionless just like the
internet
so i guess all this to say blockchains
are part of the database technology that
bitcoin and ethereum are based on
but the the cool thing about blockchains
is that they are public and
permissionless and private blockchains
that you know a company
creates or a bank creates might tap into
those public blockchains but
are as important to the story of this
whole
like new money future of money system
that we've created here
i've always thought of blockchain as
like this ledger that keeps
the record of the bitcoin transactions
yes
is that correct on a basic basic level
that is correct right so so bitcoin is
an asset but it's also a
network right so if i were to give you
bitcoin
carly then that transaction gets
recorded on this network
this this ledger this general ledger and
that is the blockchain but it's a public
blockchain
that's accessible to everyone so there
is bitcoin the asset
and there's bitcoin the the network the
blockchain and these two
are are sort of separate ideas the best
analogy someone said to explain it to me
was
blockchain is the engine so like if you
look at like if you like a car
like you have an engine in a plane you
have an engine in a helicopter
engine you know in a car like the motor
engine whatever like the
the combustible engine let's say as the
example but
cryptocurrency or bitcoin is the model t
ford
that actually changed the world that
applied to humans was usable and that
engine that blockchains can be applied
to a whole bunch of different things in
different ways and maybe those
innovations will also change the world
but right now
it's the model t4 we're making people go
get get them go wherever it is
is that accurate
yeah i think that's accurate i would say
that right so like blockchain
is just a uh it's just a technology to
enforce digital scarcity the cool thing
about something like
like a bitcoin is that um there's social
consensus that this
bitcoin blockchain is creating this new
form of money
and everyone is buying into that idea of
bitcoin
as a as a new form of money but but
there's other things you can do with
blockchain too so like there's uh
there's
bitcoin and then but there's also
ethereum which takes the idea of bitcoin
and makes uh the money system a bit more
programmable
i've heard if you're following this
casually a lot of people heard of
bitcoin
some have heard of ethereum carly
mentioned monero
i've heard of a billion others dodge
coin is whatever
elon musk is pumping right now dennis
rodman had a
like a pot coin wherever the hell like
back in the day um
explain like breaking out all of them is
gonna be too hard but maybe let's start
with bitcoin and ethereum like the
differences and then maybe
how they vary you know like what when
people like when they create a new one
is just like a fancy new name or
uh what is the mechanics of that the
thing to understand about
all of these different forms of of of
money
and cryptocurrencies uh is that they all
have something in common
um and that's that they're based on
credibly neutral protocols and this term
protocols throws people off because
crypto people use it all the time but
all a protocol is is it's a set of rules
okay a set of rules so if you think
about the importance of protocols which
we which we often don't but protocols
are at the very base layer of society
right so
the us constitution what is that that is
a protocol
for how to run a republic super
important 4
000 page document it spells out this is
how we're going to run
this republic called the united states
and what were we able to accomplish with
that protocol
well we were able to replace the kings
in england
with like the people with protocols we
took instead of the the
king's duties we we created a
constitution so we could give it back to
the people
that's what these uh crypto systems are
doing i i mentioned this term credibly
neutral because the great thing about
the us constitution
is that uh it's neutral right we we've
got sort of this balance of powers
idea so uh the concept that one
individual or dictator
uh or you know totalitarian regime can't
like assume power in the co
that's that's really important because
that makes it neutral so you want a
system that's unbiasable
that one party can't centralize and
control and the other pieces
is credible so the us constitution works
because we all believe that the us
constitution works
ron you're getting into our world here i
think we'd say it's theoretically
neutral
um but i'm with you obviously imperfect
right but
but credibly neutral for organizing
society okay
so um bitcoin and ethereum bring that
concept
to to money so bitcoin says well what
what if we were to create a credibly
neutral
monetary system that means no one can
change the rules
in terms of how much bitcoin that should
exist
right it's real it's like impossible to
change the rules it's immutable
and it's anyone can audit it anyone can
access it right that's what bitcoin is
simply it's all it is it's a credibly
neutral protocol
for money specifically there shall be
only 21 million bitcoin that exists
right that's what it says
it's like a digital gold standard in
many ways right yes yes that's exactly
that's exactly what it is
when you say it says that's what it says
who said it
well this is a great thing so like uh
you know how the constitution it's
written in a document right almost in
legal prose
essentially um well bitcoin's credibly
neutral protocol
for money is written in code so you
actually like audit the code you know
how
if you if you have a browser there's a
button you can click view source
and you see like all the all the stuff
that actually
creates the images on your screen in
your web browser you could do that with
a money system that's what bitcoin does
you can view source anyone can see it
you could see the issuance rate of
bitcoin when it trails off
and that's what makes it credibly
neutral and now it
credibly because uh there's a social
element to this movement too you ask
like what's the difference between
bitcoin and uh
dogecoin well the difference is um there
there are more people who believe
bitcoin is a money than dogecoin it is
more credibly neutral
so that's how movements kind of build
from the ground up
um i think the other part of this story
is you asked about ethereum
so ethereum then takes bitcoin right
this
idea of digital scarcity and says well
what if we could what if we generalize
that
what if instead of just creating one
type of money a bitcoin
what if we could create all sorts of
these digital assets what if we could
create
stocks what if we could create bonds
what if we could create an entire
uh credibly neutral banking system
on top of this cryptocurrency thing and
those two tools together bitcoin
and ethereum are really the tools that
uh
that i and communities like mine are
using to go bank less because
um we we have these these new
technologies and these new tools now to
do that
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by your
favorite hello tushie the coolest bidet
company
on the planet this is frankly the future
of toileting they figured it out in
europe it's time for us to figure it out
here
it's a joke because they've been using
bidets for centuries but they've always
been expensive costing thousands of
dollars and now the new
brand new hello tushy 3.0 is here to
level that playing field it's stylish
eco-friendly easy to install
and affordable it's pretty cool attaches
right to your existing toilet no
electricity
or additional plumbing and it cuts
toilet paper use by 80 percent
which is great we love saving money we
love helping the environment less paper
less money all things are great you've
got a 60-day
try it risk-free guarantee and a
12-month warranty
and these new ones essentially clean
themselves so it's pretty freaking cool
so here's how you do it go to
hellotushy.com get 10
off because you're listening to this
podcast plus you get free shipping it's
a special offer just for yank speaks
listeners so go to hellotushy.com
yang for ten percent off hellotushy.com
there's some sort of veil being lifted
on our monetary system
where compared to right now our monetary
system is
managed by the either the federal
reserve or the central bank the united
states government
which is essentially the the standard of
the world um
is it because are people interested in
this because this is democratizing the
money
and sharing it like both transparently
and theoretically eventually equally
around the world is that the driver here
or is it really like uh
the other pieces like anti-establishment
the world is ending the dollar's gonna
fail
middle finger to the world by bitcoin to
the moon i think it's a combination of
those things and for everyone who enters
it's it's a little bit different but
i do think that this is a populist
movement in some ways but it's a healthy
form of populism because
it's not saying we're going to burn down
the old system it's that it's saying
we're going to opt out we're going to
build this new awesome system
and this new system this new money
system this new financial system
is going to be based on credibly neutral
protocols right so if you think about
the
the the monetary policy of the u.s um
and when individuals think about that
well what is that controlled by
it's controlled by jerome powell and a
small group
of individuals right and they're trying
their best
i'm sure right but do they always get it
right no
they don't always get it right and do
they have undue control and have they
over the past
you know 10 to 20 years printed
money more in favor of like the
establishment and the banking system
this is back to the cantillon
cantillion effect that we were talking
about earlier where where this money
printing
is not going to average citizens in the
u.s
it's going to bankers and people who
hold assets that's why if you want to
play the
monetary game in the united states you
can't just hold dollars
in a savings account anymore right like
you're not making any money that way you
have to play the game you have to buy
assets you have to invest
and so people are saying well should a
small group of
individuals in washington be able to
uh to to turn the dials on the money
system what happens if
they become corrupt and so this is a
ground-up movement
to say no we want to build our money
system and by the way not just central
banking but also commercial banking
on credibly neutral protocols where um
you know the the that can't be biased
that can't be corrupted
uh and so this is this is kind of a
reaction to some of the the wealth
inequality that we've seen this is a
reaction to censorship this is a
reaction to
um you know hedge fund managers calling
the the owners of robin hood and saying
stop trading gamestop
right it's a reaction to all of these
things and
this is crypto's moment this is crypto's
decade i think this is why this is an
important movement for us
let me ask though because i i totally
understand the dynamic of like
the kind of establishment has been
rigging the system
and making the rules and setting the
rules for far too long and therefore
sort of the only people who have been
benefiting from the rules
but there is a movement really on the
left in the united states this like
almost modern
monetary theory camp that says look if
we can
kind of print money limitlessly
right we could in theory print money and
give it directly to people
right and like print money for for a ubi
or something like that
what concerns me about
when we look at the future of bitcoin
and these sort of um
limited currencies is is sort of what
the issue was maybe with the gold
standard which is there is a finite
amount of it
and are we going to end up in a world
where once again you have a finite
resource and it's all pooling to
elites and there's no more that can be
created
how do you respond to that or what are
people thinking about that
so i think that is a really insightful
comment carly
like i think you hit the nail on the
head and there there is um
there are different like camps and
communities inside of of cryptocurrency
so there's this strong
austrian you know economic
bent that would hate everything that you
just said about modern
monetary theory i may be in that camp
for what it's worth okay well so like
there's that camp and they say like no
government shouldn't print money
right we should we should have a
credibly neutral standard something like
a gold standard right
and that should come from from
cryptocurrency um but to your point
well what what's what's the response
when you say well that's just going to
lead to
an unequal system in the future where
people who bought in bitcoin early or
whatever
crypto early like they end up being the
the elites and the new bankers right so
that's one group in crypto
but there's another group in crypto
because it's a very you know
wide camp that thinks that well we we
have
been uh printing money and essentially
we've we've been giving out ubi
we've been giving out ubi for the last
like 20 years
but we've we've been giving it to the
wealthy right so
so maybe what we need is a ubi system
um for for um everyone else the citizens
right this is kind of andrew yang's
platform
and well with cryptocurrency with with
uh systems like ethereum
this makes a a great path for
distributing that money right so like
i i don't know but getting a check from
the irs
or whoever issued it that you know for
for um
covid you know stimulus basically that
was a very long process
what if you could just hit a button and
a digital currency
from issued by the central banks in the
us just appeared in your wallet right
so like so like this is the type of
innovation we could tap into and there's
a whole side of the crypto community
that's like
hey you know uh we don't think that
bottom-up money
like a bitcoin or an ether should be
outlawed
right we think that people should have
that option but we also think that that
central banks
should play a role in this and they
should promote
better distribution of their money
through things like ubi and
cryptocurrency can be uh
and you know can be sort of a conduit in
a network to make that more efficient
um so you'll find both both sides of the
camp uh
represented in the in the crypto
community i think i believe it's bitcoin
in particular
they have done some work on regulation
they have
been working with governments to prevent
the money laundering piece of this
because the down the dark side of
cryptocurrency is that
if it's completely anonymous really like
you can't follow the money anymore and
you end up in some really really
really dark places um so talk to me a
bit about where we are today
on what's called the regulation of this
or not any regulation like how
governments have been working with the
cryptocurrency community
or not working with them we're not
working yeah we are afraid of them
so that so the crypto community the
internet community has has always talked
about government as kind of the final
boss right it's like
pop its head up and shut down the
internet right so much so
that's been an ongoing meme and i i
would just say that that's been an
ongoing mean since
since kind of the birth of of bitcoin
but um what i would say is the the the
regulatory
regime in the u.s and in most countries
around the world has actually been
surprisingly friendly to crypto
um which is which is which is great uh
so
you know the banks are now bank charters
can now custody crypto assets in the us
uh the commodities the cftc the
commodities future exchange
has just said that bitcoin is a
commodity so it can be regulated that
way and so is ether a commodity
um there's been no move to really outlaw
cryptocurrencies
i think par part of the reason for this
and by the way
on the comment about sort of uh you know
anonymous cash
and the hazards of that well i mean the
the biggest anonymous cash
and money laundering actually happens
with like dollars right
it's actually if you want to launder if
you want to launder money
cash is easier yeah it's way easier like
there's fiat on ramps to crypto
it's it's open but it's not completely
private
in in bitcoin or in ethereum so if you
want to launder money
like don't do this guys but like cash is
the way to do it benjamin's that's what
briefcase is full of things breaking bad
i know your time i'm just you know
so so um so anyway it's it's actually
not a good tool for flaunting money and
i think
what's what's happening is governments
are realizing that there are far more
wins
uh than than losses with the adoption of
crypto there's going to be a whole new
kind of
where's the crypto silicon valley going
to be located is that going to be in the
jurisdiction of the us or is it going to
be another country are we gonna
like what about uh distribution of
central bank digital currencies well
those should happen on public networks
like like ethereum so
there are all of these efficiency wins
that governments have similar to the
early internet like the early internet
it's a little bit scary to say
we've got this communication protocol
anyone in the world can spin up a
website
and you know start projecting whatever
ideas they have that's a little bit
scary for governments right
but the wins uh in adopting that
protocol the protocol of the internet
far outweighed the losses and so
everybody did it and i think that's
that's what's happening with governments
around the world is
is they're all adopting this technology
for the wins
i'm so excited to watch prime ministers
and global leaders talk about dodge coin
or
whatever dreams we whip up um
it's gonna be exciting and i i believe
if you do not understand this you're
unfit to lead
because this same community just wiped
out wall street for about a week
um like this is real and it's
frustrating to watch leaders
pretend they don't understand it or
think it's like a weird internet culture
thing
on the other hand is there a certain
advantage again i
worry about these kinds of technologies
ultimately being co-opted by sort of
these elite institutions and
undermining the very sort of advantages
they provide which is this like
democratization effect right and so is
there a certain advantage
that call it the internet right now has
in that a lot of leaders don't
necessarily fully understand this and it
kind of gives us an opportunity to make
sure it sort of
is implemented democratically you know
before you know before sort of these
column elite institutions or
establishment institutions are able to
really kind of co-opt them and
manipulate them to their own gains
totally i think the birth story
like we talked about cryptos it almost
had an immaculate conception because all
along the establishment has
has has shunned it right it's like oh
it's too volatile to be a money right
for like the the boom and bust cycles
like of course every time they said this
is like a
you know a a a tulips kind of
like fad and it's all going to to fade
out every single cycle they said this
and so uh what what's happened is people
have been the first to adopt it
developers internet natives have been
the first to adopt it
i think it would be far less interesting
if in like year one
of bitcoin the us government just bought
all the bitcoin
right and that's not going to distribute
cryptocurrency to the people
the other thing i'll say to you is like
one concern i have
being in cryptocurrency is back to
exactly what you said carly which is
like
we have to make sure that we're not just
creating a new crypto system
with like bitcoin as the gold standard
and we get a new set of bankers but
they're still bankers right
this is why ethereum is so important
this is why this idea of decentralized
finance is important because bitcoin
just gives you sort of a money
but that that money is often custodied
in this new
set of banks called crypto banks these
are the coin bases and gemini's of the
world
with ethereum what what you get is the
ability to actually do the banking
yourself in a self-sovereign way it
creates like banks
as proto as protocols on top of it so
that's sort of we can get into
what it means to go bankless but that's
sort of what what we're talking about
going bankless means
actually replacing the banks wholesale
not creating a new set of banks
replacing the banks with these credibly
neutral protocols and this is the idea
of open finance or decentralized finance
if you've heard those terms
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by literati kids
if you like reading and you think
children should read this is a product
for you so great children's books opens
up new worlds for discovery with
literary kids your child can explore
uncharted places every month with
incredible stories hand-picked by
experts so literary kids is a try before
you buy subscription book club each
month literati delivers five
vibrantly illustrated children's books
bringing the immersive magic of reading
right to your home and they've got
age-based book clubs they ensure
appropriate reads so for story time
letting them read on their own i
personally grew up loving
choose your own adventure books i also
love that the berenstein bears freaking
love them so you can get all this
awesomeness brought to your children
with a cool monthly subscription through
literary kids so head to literary.com
slash yang for 25 off your first two
orders it's pretty awesome 25
off folks select your child's book club
and start them on a literary journey
like no other
literati.com slash yang's the only place
you can find 25
off your first two orders and this
one-of-a-kind book subscription is the
most joyful way to foster
a lifelong love of learning for kids so
literati.com
[Music]
so let's let's dive into this talking
about
what this starts to look like in
practice for people because it's fun to
say
we're getting rid of banks it's fun to
say we've got crypto we got this new
currency
like the dollar is not what it is to be
it's fun to say power to the people
right but what what does this mean so
there's four categories i want to
dive into in some capacity and we'll
figure out what's much more interesting
i want to talk about regular
transactions
i want to talk about personal like
accounting checking savings that sort of
thing i want to talk about the
investment piece without my assets and
the banking and
stock market and then the lastly is like
the government
oversight central banking federal
reserve like how this all
intertwines um so let's start with the
first one
um basic transactions like what does it
look like i'm a human being and maybe
that's kind of combined with the
personal checking and savings too but
start with like i'm gonna go buy
starbucks
10 years from now and we're all using
bitcoin or ethereum whatever it is
what can that look like yeah so
uh what's so cool about this is uh we
are totally early
right so so i don't know you guys
remember the early 90s and the internet
sucked and it was like
you know dial up and it was only for
geeks and it was just a very small
community right
hey hey i use aol and you remember the
aim
that you got mail situation yeah yeah i
mean you remember if mom picked up the
phone
basically yeah yeah
i'm like dating myself i'm 33 those of
you i know probably younger
some of you well somebody older hope you
feel like pain anyway keep going
okay so like the youngsters might not
remember but you and i remember these
days zach and
the internet was was pretty clunky it's
hard to use that's where we are right
now so
basically population who owns
cryptocurrency right now is probably
about like 60 to
80 million but they just do one thing
with it they hold people
or globally globally uh but they just do
one thing with it hold
okay so like what what we're doing in
kind of bankless is doing more than hold
and i think of what you just said is
like checking accounts and investing
accounts and
um you know payment accounts all of
these things these are like the money
verbs
that we do right so think of what's
what's a money verb hold is one verb
you can like store your wealth and hold
it but pay is another verb
and lend is another verb and trade is
another verb right and
what is banking it's all of these money
verbs put together
right like that's what banking is and so
back to this idea of
people need banking but we don't
necessarily need banks
right that that's the idea so what what
can you do right now
um let's talk about that first i guess
money verb that's sort of the
the pay money verb and this has been
kind of the holy grail for for crypto
when am i going to be able to buy my
starbucks with uh with bitcoin
well it turns out that uh bitcoin or
ether for that matter which is the
cryptocurrency of ethereum
these are not good assets to spend with
and do you know why
it's because bitcoin pizza guy somebody
spent
uh first bitcoin transaction in like it
was like 2012 or something
uh and he bought a pizza with it okay
and
uh so spent bitcoin on pizza
and the cost of that transaction in
today's terms is like
tens of millions of dollars because the
thing that you want to do
with bitcoin is hold it because it
appreciates in value it's a scarce asset
it's not stable like the us dollar so
the way
crypto business in gold exactly it's
just like it's something you want to
store and hold it's not something that
you want to pay your regular
transactions with so
but what cryptocurrency over the last
three years has done
is created a less volatile form of
cryptocurrency
called a stablecoin or a crypto dollar
so this is a cryptocurrency that just
tracks the us dollar
some of these are are trustless some of
these are trusted issued by banks
we could get into that later but now
what you can do is
i actually have a visa card where i can
go into starbucks
and i can swipe that visa card and i'm
actually paying with crypto
through the visa network connected to a
bridge to crypto
and i'm paying with uh stable coins with
uh crypto dollars essentially it's
essentially dollars right
it's not bitcoin well it's some of it is
and some of it isn't so some of it is
like dollars so there's a
there's it's on cryptocurrency the
network it's on the blockchain but it's
like mapped to a bank somewhere but some
of it is actually backed by
an asset like ether so it's like do you
know in the old days
where like long time ago when the us
dollar was backed by gold
um some of it's some of it's like that
right so some of it is dollars that are
backed by ether anyway
cryptocurrency has solved that problem
so we have a way to pay with our
cryptocurrency using stable coins
and there's now something like 30 to 50
billion
dollars worth of crypto stable coins out
there now
and this has grown like 50-fold 100-fold
over the last 18 months like just a
massive amount of growth which sounds
like a healthy hybrid between
using bitcoin purely or using ethereum
or whatever like crypto
purely and using a dollar which is
probably the bridge you want
to get started right now exactly awkward
time so it's
and it's something that didn't exist so
the volatility problem
uh it didn't exist like in the early
days of bitcoin and it does now
what steps need to happen to like get
past this interim stage where you're
still using a visa card to pay for it
like how far
down the road and is there a world where
we're all kind of using bitcoin down the
road or a dollar
version using a bitcoin in starbucks and
what does that look like
i think that uh payment like in that way
that you're talking about might actually
be uh like last mile that might actually
be the final thing
that crypto solves right so right now if
if you're kind of geeky if you're
like me you can open up uh an ether
account right an ethereum account
and i could pay you with stable coins
without going through the
visa network if you have an ethereum
account so i could just say
here's some dollars i'm going to pay you
zack you know ten dollars worth of
stable coins
and there's no transaction in the middle
but to upgrade the world's
proof like um systems so that starbucks
that that's going to take some time to
upgrade those systems so there's the
capability now
but to upgrade all of that
infrastructure will take some time but
there are some other things that you can
do
in crypto now i would argue that are far
better than you can do in the
traditional system so you mentioned
another thing which is
checking and savings accounts that's
like way better in crypto even today
like right now
because it grows well so i mean i don't
know if you guys have checked
your your your bank uh checking account
or savings account at the interest rate
right but it's like 0.001
it's really sad it's really sad um in
crypto you can open up
savings accounts and checking accounts
again using
your uh ethereum address as sort of your
bank account an ethereum address is like
a bank account
uh and you can get far better interest
rates like i'm talking like eight
percent
i'm talking ten percent and this is base
this is on crypto dollars
does it have the same downside risk
though because that's one of the fears
that you buy bitcoin like oh you know
it's gonna it could go to zero tomorrow
and it could go back up this is 40 grand
whatever it is right now um
that's what's cool because of uh you
have stable coins i could actually
like just use these stable coins and be
earning a six seven eight percent 10
interest rate in the crypto system and i
can't get that anywhere
in the traditional financial system bank
account today right so like
this is a it's like working in crypto
can be like working
in a uh a banking system with
superpowers right like this is
it if you learn this is the um it
it's a pain and it's hard and user
experience isn't there but there's also
a lot of
upside in being on the bleeding edge in
the frontier and
you can't get these types of interest
rates anywhere else right if someone
wanted
to do that right now let's say that
person zack and carly
um because we're nodding and smiling
here um how does one do that and if it's
a link
i'm going to put it in the episode
description
um for the world how does that how do
you do this well so the first step is
you actually have to own some
cryptocurrency right so
money app right so um
i mean it depends how much you want to
buy how much do you want to buy right so
let's say let's say i want to put a
couple grand in that too little do i
have to have what's like the minimum
no way you could put a hundred dollars
you could a thousand dollars
whatever you want yeah it's get started
with ten dollars with you know twenty
dollars
cool so um there's like these two
financial systems right now there's the
old we call it old fi
like the old financial system on the
other side and then there's this new
decentralized financial system and the
bridge between those things
is what's known as a crypto exchange so
there are lots of crypto exchanges
um gemini is one uh coinbase is another
if you're if you're in the us
and so what you do is you create a an
account on the crypto exchange
and then you take some of your dollars
from your u.s bank account
and you ach transfer it to a coin base
or a gemini
and then you buy some crypto you don't
have to buy bitcoin or
ether you can if you want to speculate
on the upside of those assets
you could just buy crypto dollars so you
could buy something called usdc
which is a crypto dollar then you could
take that crypto dollar
and you can move it from coinbase into a
an ethereum address and start getting
into this
this bankless money system and start you
know parking it into a decentralized
finance
interest account for instance so like to
do this
inter in terms of level of
sophistication like it's probably about
an
hour of time uh and i don't know
like i i think basically anyone can can
can do this at this point it takes just
a little bit of
it's it's dial-up modem days so it just
takes a little bit of finesse and
it's a little more troublesome than than
it will be in the future but the user
experience is getting better
what is there like a resource for folks
can like go and and maybe read this
six or thirty times to understand
exactly what
that all means is there like a good
place that folks can kind of like
learn a little bit more about getting
started on this journey yeah we try to
do that with bank lists so we have like
a guide of like if if you're going from
zero to
uh to crypto um you can do these these
steps and this is how you go from like
your bank account to
a crypto bank account to decentralized
finance
what's your website it's
newsletter.banklesshq.com and you'll
want to go to the guide so we have
it's called guide1 i'm going to paste
this link when this episode drops
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by athletic greens the most
comprehensive daily nutritional beverage
you are going to find his deal you get
some athletic greens comes in little
pouches or like a little bowl of powder
however you want to do it
dump it into some water mix it up drink
it and it tastes great when i was with
my sister she put it in a smoothie for
me it's amazing too but you don't need
it it tastes good and it's this
all-in-one superfood powder by far the
easiest most delicious
nutritional habit you can add your
health routine today helps your gut it
has 75 vitamins minerals whole foods
sourced ingredients it's got all that
good stuff
you get when you eat veggies pretty cool
easy to use and because it's podcast
you can get a discount on athletic means
and some free vitamin d
so what's that discount you get a free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit our link today
so whether you're looking for better
performance or better health athletic
greens makes it easy so visit
athleticgreens.com
join health experts athletes and health
conscious go-getters around the world
make a daily commitment to help every
day that's
athleticgreens.com get your free supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
[Music]
are there organizations or people that
are working on making sure that
that these resources really are
available to maybe communities today
that
lack an access to credit in our
traditional systems right like
plugging this gap um that very much
exists in the financial system today for
those
you know i think of women and
communities of color and and people who
have often been
been more on the outskirts of the
traditional system
i think the answer to that question is
not yet so
right now this is skewed towards the
geeks basically
um the good news is if you're a geek in
argentina
or argentina or venezuela and
you can't get access to a banking system
because you're literally shut out
there's capital controls
right then you can use this crypto
banking system so that's
access from an international perspective
like you know i know people using
stable coins in argentina to to escape
sort of the
the inflation traps there uh and also to
like i mean
uh to actually use their money um so
from that perspective yes but it's still
skewed a little bit towards
towards the geeks right now um but this
is again
you know uh 1983 first cell phone comes
up
it's a brick and it costs four thousand
dollars right that's how technology
works it
it starts there and then it gradually as
it improves becomes more and more
accessible
and i think that's what we'll see with
with crypto and it will start to reach
these underserved communities
uh in ways that the banking system
hasn't whether that's international or
in the us interesting well that that
strikes me as an opportunity for folks
who are listening who understand
cryptocurrency i feel like figuring out
a way to start bridging some of those
those gaps in places where it doesn't
exist uh hit me up if you're interested
in that i'm interested in that
let me ask you this um and this is a
question our producer
suggested me which is a good one um so
soraya is our producer he's always
behind the scenes and for those of you
who want to know
what makes the yang speak podcast worth
it's all soraya um
but the our question is really good is
that
this new crypto space is all
it's all online right it's not
the gold backed or there's no physical
dollars there's no technical physical
cash like what happens if what's called
catastrophe strikes like electricity
outage
or um i know a lot of stuff can't be
hacked but maybe it can be wiped
right like like if the data disappears
um
some of those risks still exist with the
dollar but definitely more so here
because there's no real physical
asset have there been discussions on
the impact of this uh if or the risk of
this
given that it's all in zeros and ones
on you know powered by electricity i
think that cryptocurrency the
the the sophisticated networks the
hardened networks like a bitcoin
ethereum are
are really designed to work if the
internet works if the internet is up
right so that that has some dependencies
as we know
the internet has to be up uh electricity
has to be on
if those if those things are not
functional
um then definitely probably humanity has
some big problems going on
and like we might be in a place where
we're reverting back to things like
like gold in the physical world um so
yes there are some dependencies but
the dependency is is kind of like that
the internet stays on
you'd have the same problem with the
dollar system i imagine if we yeah we'd
have a lot of
like the data tracking right if it all
blew up like would this
like at least with a dollar like the
banks have still are using paper records
to keep their
you know um i don't know if you ever
watch mr robot um
but it's a movie about hackers and they
literally hack the world's financial
system
but they had backed it up physically so
after hell
for like three months the banks and the
large corporations
were able to like level reset everybody
where they were wealth-wise
um is that even an option in cri
like a crypto like like you know i don't
understand the technology enough to know
that if everything got hacked
like would it all just go to zero or
would you be able to reset
you could definitely reset so if there
was some sort of issue with a bitcoin or
an ethereum
and let's say um bitcoin did the thing
it's never supposed to do and suddenly
someone found a vulnerability to print
you know a million extra bitcoin give it
to themselves right
well what would happen in that case is
the community would no longer accept
that bitcoin
they would say that's a the wrong
bitcoin and then
the fake bitcoin everybody socially that
that's what backs all of these systems
like we the protocol of the constitution
it's still people
at the very bottom so it's enforced by
like the constitution which is like
legal script in a document
and the same way bitcoin or an ethereum
is enforced by code
but there's still a social system
there's still people as the
the bottom layer of it we call that like
the layer zero so what would happen is
they would just
move to the real bitcoin rather than uh
letting the hack kind of spoil it
and i think in in a lot of ways um
crypto systems are more resilient to
attack so if you think about a an
authoritarian country
that maybe decides that if you're a
political dissident
uh you no longer have access like your
social credit score is diminished you no
longer have access to the banking system
we're gonna shut you out well
no one can shut you out of your ethereum
address like no one can it's impossible
as long as you have a keyboard
your private key access the internet
it's uncensorable no one can shut it
down no one can take it away from you
so it's more resilient uh to to those
types of threats
i think which is which is important for
us right there are some like tragic
stories right of folks who have like
millions of dollars now in bitcoin and
they like can't remember their key and
yes
can't and they literally have like
they're like multi-millionaires and they
just don't have access to it and there's
no way to get it because of the way this
works
yeah that's my understanding is that
right you should probably sell for that
i don't know how we talk about this is
this like going on the oregon trail
like heading west right like it's
dangerous this is definitely the
frontier right so if you screw up you
can lose stuff at this stage
it's getting better but um like still
keep keep those things in mind
um because what you're talking about
carly absolutely does happen if you lose
your private keys just like if you lost
cash or if you lost gold it's gone
like it's gone so it's not for the faint
of heart
when you're thinking about crypto i
think the average person is like whoa
new money new currency like this is no
like come on like the
current system is working enough like
what are you trying to do right
but at the end of the day our dollar
is a dollar physically is worth nothing
it's literally worthless
um it's worth the cost of the paper or
whatever it is or ones and zeros um
and the reason it's worth something is
because we trust
that it's worth something we trust in
our government
and as our government is either not
keeping up with the people
or the times and people are losing trust
in their government
it is not infeasible that we start to
put trust in our people and if
cryptocurrency
to your point ryan is backed by people
and the trust of people and this
collective
transparency it's called a digital
constitution the way you're talking
about how this works
it isn't infeasible to me that we put
trust in this currency and we actually
over time start to prefer
this because of how its trust has built
that's what this is uh this is money by
the people for the people
and it is a check and balance on the
government
um central banks will have to level up
their game
right and that's a good thing for the
people
that's a good thing for ubi and getting
like money in the hands of the people
they have to compete
with these non-sovereign currencies so
this is a technology of
of freedom we think about like major
technology buckets that are coming in
our lifetime right like artificial
intelligence
that like centralizes a whole bunch of
things cryptocurrency
decentralizes it it gives power back to
the individual
and to the people i like to say like if
you're if you're scared of an
open permissionless credibly neutral
opt-in financial system
if that that strikes fear in your heart
maybe that says something about you
right like oh wow this is kind of like
this is completely opt-in it's by
definition
optional and we're building it from from
the ground up as a better system
so i hope nation states
compete i hope they do because that will
be better for the world better for
humanity
and by the way crypto's not going to do
everything that a nation can do
ever it can't build hospitals it can't
build roads it can't provide
health care uh it can't you know protect
citizens
so i think that governments will come to
the realization that this is actually a
healthy relationship
and maybe we need a bit of separation of
money and state in the way we separated
and the way we separated religion and
state um this is a good thing for
humanity
i love your optimism ryan i sure as heck
hope you're right
i i look at the world around us i look
at how
people in power will do virtually
anything to stay in power
and i very much worry about what they'll
do to either
shut down some of these systems these
nascent systems right before they have
the opportunity to fulfill their
potential
because the governments and and people
in power see them as threats because
they don't understand them
or alternatively will and maybe i'm
misunderstanding it because it's not
possible for them to fully co-opt them
but will in some ways kind of co-opt
these systems so again it's meet the new
boss name as the old boss
relatedly and secondarily i think i
think the promise of this is awesome
and i want to participate and i'm going
to read all the resources i can and i
want to understand all of this better
um but i do think you know to the point
that we were sort of making earlier i
think you're
you're talking about geeks you're
talking about a lot of you know a lot of
white guys who are who are sort of at
the forefront of this
right and that's not to put judgment on
them or or this but you know it again it
sort of meet the new boss name as the
old boss and i
i really would love to see or understand
how
as we are in the early stages of this we
can make it a more inclusive community
so
that the the boats that are being lifted
at the end of this
um look more like the world we want to
see and and i think there's a real
opportunity because of that
um i think that you know as we talk
about
equality in the in the world uh
you know this is the kind of thing that
i think almost offers the most promise
to me
over so many other solutions that we
maybe talk about um
so i think there's a lot of promise and
i think it also the fear that gets
struck in my heart is that
the promise won't be fulfilled
absolutely well carly i i think you
nailed it right like you nailed the the
original meme of crypto which is like
the final boss is coming
uh you you nailed sort of the bankless
concern which is
let's not just replicate a new class of
bankers let's actually create a more
accessible money for the people
one thing i'll say on kind of the last
point is i i totally agree we need more
people
from different communities involved in
this movement that's why part of it is
uh
trying to make the knowledge here more
accessible that's part of definitely
what we're doing
at bankless one other thing i'll say
though is um
you know i think the reality is it's not
going to be optimally accessible
right now in day one for every community
but the hope is
that just like the internet which was
you know created in university campuses
with with elites and all sorts of things
that
the technology that they create then
becomes a substrate
for greater access and some social
benefit for the rest of society
once technology improves it to make the
user experience better so
i know that there's kind of a limited
set of like geeks and early adopters who
are involved here
but i think that the the credibly
neutral substrate that they're building
is going to be beneficial uh to the
world in the long run
in the ways that the original internet
was so
hopefully i think it's awesome i really
do i mean i think that i think it's so
interesting to think about these things
and
and uh and i love the promise that it
that it sort of represents and what it
could be
for sure used to run a non-profit and
started um called suit up and
we do a lot of work in kind of tougher
communities here in new york
particularly and
if i was like if it doesn't work for
those kids if it doesn't work for their
mom
many times a single mom raising raising
the boys and girls that we're working
with
it doesn't work for her it's probably
not gonna work
um and i think of the fosse family when
we worked in new hampshire if it's not
working for jodie fosse who's
doing everything as her head down trying
to put food on the table for her family
it's not going to work um so that that's
the key
right where we um we could have this
amazing
upside but if it's only working for the
same people that the other system worked
for we're toast
i've said this i'm going to say this at
the end of every episode is ryan
we're going to have you back on this
podcast in 10 years and
you're either going to say i told you so
or i'm going to be like dude you were so
wrong um and i'll be fine let that well
ryan what what is the timeline
do you have a sense of timeline because
i remember so i i listened to
a planet money episode about bitcoin
probably 10 years back
or so and they were making bets about
like you know what was what was bitcoin
gonna be in 10 years and
you know they probably were their bets
weren't necessarily wrong they were just
the timeline wasn't right what do you
think the timeline is for
for like cryptocurrency being call it
like really mainstream or like
everyday people using it do you have a
prediction on that
2020s it's happening this decade oh okay
this is where we go
here it is absolutely 2020. so we'll by
the end of this decade we'll have at
least a billion people
using cryptocurrencies in some form
market cap will be
into the trillion so it'll be a globally
significant it's already in the
trillions but it'll be a globally
significant monetary asset
i think it all goes down this decade i
think that this is like
the first decade was you know building
and figuring this stuff out and
the next decade is uh is scaling it so
this is the
bring crypto yes bring bring me on in
ten years we'll see if that turns out
but
um i'm pretty excited about the future
here all right
yang gang we are leading the decade of
crypto um
this is not an investment recommendation
podcast and you should use your own
money however you want but i'm going to
buy crypto so you sold me
ryan for what it's i worth stablecoin
or stablecoin or something i don't know
i'll keep everybody updated on this but
regardless
um ryan thank you for your time thank
you for your expertise
i learned a ton hopefully those of you
listening did as well carly thank you
for balancing
everyone and asking the right questions
over and over
um this was a blast thank you for
joining the future of money
krypto plus the yang gang baby there you
go
[Music]
you